good to see you both i kind of wish we
got a five six seven eight to start the
uh
[Laughter]
right we got to get going on this thing
um early
how rose how would you say
that sheila in season two is is handling
her evolution
well we've made her and she's sort of in
her quote unquote recovery from her
eating disorder and we see as it goes on
what that actually really looks like and
what a real recovery looks like and this
is not what a real recovery looks like
she's still living a double life she's
still
very much
you know hiding everything from from her
husband but but in a way season two
deals with more of the external fights
sheila has whether it's like in her
marriage or in her place of work and
trying to like climb the ladder at this
very kind of conservative conventional
company
um and to be taken seriously and kind of
like what a slog it is like trying to be
a
fitness guru and then coming across
murray bartlett's character i think is a
great turning point who plays he plays
vinnie green this season who is
sheila's sort of mentor slash rival and
what that kind of looks like uh
so it was fun but i feel like the whole
season really opens up a lot into a lot
of other characters lives yeah
and now you mentioned that like the
conflict at work and we know that greta
is like
ride or die for for sheila like she's
inner corner even though they don't
always
see eye to eye
right do you think that that's a good
example of like mixing friendship with
work
yeah sure i mean people are complicated
i think some some friends work better
than others i've always said that i
think um
greta would say sheila's her best friend
and sheila would not say that greta was
hers and season one i used to sing all
the time to rose like you love this
[Laughter]
in this season they i think they become
better friends in in a truer sense and
and it empowers greta to feel like she
can be a part of what sheila is building
that she always has believed in her but
for the first time greta's like
i am also capable of building something
she always thought sheila was like on a
pedestal and greta starts to go i'm i'm
a capable person too so the friendship
that opens that up for her i think
yeah
you know the
ever since i started watching the show
even the last season i started paying
way more attention to like what my inner
voice was saying and when i was catching
myself being like oh this is bad like
this is toxic for me how has doing this
show actually affected the way that you
talk to yourselves
yeah i think it makes you more aware i
totally it's a human condition you know
we carry this consciousness this
monologue with us of feelings and
thoughts and
knowing what to pay attention to what is
like a true
voice in your space and what is the
noise and the exterior and
and it's obviously very complicated yeah
like that's where there's like
you know
books and theories and websites and you
know
lives dedicated to trying to throw
different ideas at you yeah to help or
or not help you know um and i i love
that this um you know physical really
deals with that yeah yeah anytime uh you
mentioned murray i just i just had the
pleasure of talking to him a minute ago
we were joking about him starting his
own fitness class
if i would take it
i was gonna say like if there's any
who in your cast would you like
be at their fitness class every single
day like who would you love to be their
your fitness instructor or rory
scovilles because i'd probably laugh and
we wouldn't work
[Laughter]
so out yep or annie annie's a good
dancer annie weissman is a really she's
always dancing around set and i i'd
dance with her she'd be cutie
um finally you know this idea of fake it
till you make it or at least put on
another character when you're out there
versus the one that's talking to you in
your head is a huge theme for every
character actually i feel like in this
season
um
how much has that played into your life
personally professionally
i think it's it's a worthy concept
sometimes you do need to do that you
just need to
kind of put it on and then it's another
part of the performance whether you're
in life but um
and i do think the show examines that in
a way and sort of the the blessings and
the curses of doing that if you will
it's totally true i'm doing it right now
i'm not actually even here
you're channeling no i think i 100 agree
with you it's you know sometimes you you
have to put the confidence out first
before it actually
develops or you know the business idea
out first before you you just have to
believe in yourself yeah yeah
yeah fantastic well thank you so much
for the time congratulations on season
okay